here to present the award for direction
an actress who is twice won the Academy
Award Miss Olivia de Havilland ladies
government those nominated for the best
achievement in directing are by fingers
20th Century Fox Joseph L mankiewicz the
greatest show on earth
DeMille paramount Cecil B DeMille High
Noon Kramer United Artists Fred
Zinnemann Moulin Rouge
Romulus United Artists John Huston the
quiet man Argosy Republic John Ford the
winner is in the absence of the winner
John Wayne will accept the award for
John
I keep remembering stagecoach long
voyage home she wore a yellow ribbon and
many other pictures that mr. Ford
directed me and naturally as ahem I'd
remember the things that I was in but I
also remember how green was my Valley
and the informer Grapes of Wrath and
other pictures that makes me very
grateful that he asked me to be his
proxy
and accept this award not to receive the
money but the award for him I'll take it
to his home on orden Street Place he's
lived in for 35 years and proudly placed
this on his mantle with five other
previous Academy Awards
must be great to have a shelf like that